roland perez et avec lequel avocate
sylvie vartan bercy alors c'est vrai que
c'est une saga cette histoire alors
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant cette audience on n'élit pas
grand chose alors 6 6 s'est passé une
chose très importante c'est à dire qu'on
devait avoir un calendrier un peu
classique d'une procédure qui devait un
peu s'éterniser sur de longs mois
et puis il y a eu deux choses
importantes la première c'est que le
président a proposé ce qui est tout à
fait normal eh bien c'est la loi la
nouvelle loi d'ailleurs de modernisation
de la justice qu'il prévoit une
conciliation une médiation
il s'est dit que a priori si les parties
pouvaient directement se parler puisque
la médiation c'est plus les avocats
assez les parties prennent un peu le
pouvoir et qu'ils discutent avec un
médiateur
donc la médiation a été proposé l'avocat
de laetitia hallyday a refusé c'est leur
médiation il a refusé
il a refusé d'abord parce que je pense
qu'il pense avoir des arguments sérieux
pour tenter d'obtenir que le procès soit
déporté c'est-à-dire qu'ils soient
déportés ailleurs c'est en france pour
demander l'application d'une loi la loi
californienne est d'accord donc il veut
d'abord jouer c'est de cet argument
c'est un argument de forme de
compétences avant même d'aborder le fond
du dossier
donc ça veut pas dire qu'il refusera
plus tard la médiation il veut dire
simplement qu'il a un argument qu'il
pense en tout cas massue qui est cet
argument de procédure et de compétence
territoriale et il veut jouer d'abord de
cet argument avant d'arriver sur une
médiation qui peut soit rapproché les
chu les légions et les partis soi même
rallongé finalement le débat le conflit
alors il ya plein de sujets qui ont été
évoqués sur cette affaire et là
maintenant il ya un guichet on dit que
laëtitia souffrirait de problèmes
d'argent
le sujet a même été évoqué sur bfm tv
regarder laeticia hallyday sur la tombe
de son mari à saint barthélemy lors des
dernières vacances avec ses filles pour
rentrer chez elle à los angeles
laëtitia a pris des vols sur des lignes
régulières la presse people l'a dit déjà
obligé de réduire toutes ses dépenses
mais dans l'eifel laetitia n'était pas
la personne qui dépensait le plus dans
le couple c'est johnny qui était connu
pour faire des folies
et là on a une jeune femme donc qui est
toujours en deuil
on imagine bien que dans ce genre de
situation a pas dit
demain tiens je vais les machines et
bijoux je vais aller m'acheter une
voiture alors c'est vrai que quand on
rentre vraiment dans la dent donc sans
vie privée c'est fou volant est ce que
ça peut jouer ça au niveau du procès ou
pas oui effectivement l'impact matériel
l'appareil d'argent peut faire en sorte
que les parties se rapprochent plus vite
que prévu pour tenter de trouver un
accord alors sur le fait qu'elle que
laetitia serait aujourd'hui dépourvues
de fond je ne crois pas je pense que la
situation malheureusement été celle
qu'on connaît c'est à dire que johnny
hallyday était malheureusement on le
savait condamné je pense que les choses
ont été mises en place bien avant je
pense que il a été dit d'ailleurs que l'
avance sur l'album a déjà été versée
évidemment que l'album soit terminé et
il n'est pas encore sorti aujourd'hui je
pense qu'ils avaient des comptes
courants qui n'ont pas été bloqués je
pense que il y a aussi des maisons aux
états unis qui ne font pas l'objet
aujourd'hui également d'un gel donc non
je pense que dans l'ensemble dans
l'ensemble de ces éléments je pense
qu'elle n'est pas aujourd'hui privés de
moyens matériels ya un biographe à
laurent lavige qui en a marre de ces
rumeurs sur laëtitia
il déclare qu'elle disposerait encore de
beaucoup d'argent regardez il a voulu
s'exprimer on regarde les réseaux
sociaux moi j'ai l'impression de
retomber en enfance ou savez ces livres
de martin alors là il ya martin à saint
barth martine à la plage mais c'est la
vie des alizés ces dernières c'est ça
martine en écho martin au mcdo je trouve
que c'est il y à une communication enfin
autour de cela effectivement où on
essaie de redonner de redorer le blason
de laetitia en disant que effectivement
depuis qu à les attaquer laëtitia a
beaucoup moins d'argent terrasse au
qu'on n'oublie dire c'est que laëtitia a
ouvert elle aussi un trust derrière où
il y à entre 20 et 30 ou 40 ou 50
millions pour rien que pour elle donc il
faut juste garder raison
alors aujourd'hui un point assez inédit
aussi qui a été évoqué c'est le point de
jade et joy dès l'es2 fille de johnny et
laeticia et apparemment elle non plus ne
toucherait rien de l'héritage ses skis
alors non je crois que c'est pas tout à
fait exact ce qui se passe c'est que
aujourd'hui laetitia laeticia hallyday
smet est aujourd'hui la légataire
universel finalement comme cela peut
être prévu d'ailleurs en français
d'accéder pouze la dernière épouse qui
est aujourd'hui qui reçoit l'ensemble
des biens qui va a théoriquement les
gérer en bon père de famille et ses
enfants viendront évidemment sa
succession est une femme jeune mais si
elle venait demain à décéder
théoriquement c'est
évidemment ces enfants qui hériteront et
notamment ses deux filles ou d'autres
enfants qu'elle pourrait avoir après
alors un ce calendrier a été défini pour
pendant le procès parce qu'on dit que ça
pourrait durer pendant cinq ou dix on
est alors en fait ce qui était prévu
aujourd'hui lisons tout est gelé
alors oui bah là la procédure de référé
ac en sorte que les biens en tout cas
les droits artistiques soit gelée et et
que c'est bien français des biens
immobiliers le sont aussi
non ce qui se passe c'est que le 22
novembre prochain au lieu de prévoir
justement un calendrier de procédure
avec des conclusions la production des
preuves etc
il a été prévu cette fois ci une
audience où on va statuer sur la
compétence est ce que le droit américain
le droit californien doit s'appliquer
est-ce que de ce fait le tribunal de
grande instance de notaire et de
nanterre est compétent c'est la question
qui est posée aujourd'hui au tribunal et
sur lesquels les magistrats vont statuer
le 22/09 empêcher les mois je fais 1 co
10 ans je crois pas du tout je suis
persuadé que temps de trouver un
arrangement avant jean michel je
voudrais savoir si les titans là
venaient non mais on joue la voir votre
avis donc oui oui je voulais savoir si
laeticia venait à accepter la médiation
à partir de quelle hauteur
la partie adverse accepterait un
compromis à quelle hauteur du
pourcentage le pourcentage de zellik ça
franchement je peux pas seulement 20% 30
pour marier lorsqu'elle a duré cinq ou
dix ans là on est encore dans la posture
on montre ses muscles
mais c'est évident pour moi je sais pas
ce qu'en pense roland que les deux
parties vont se rapprocher en coulisses
je crois qu'à une chaussure à la matière
est une posture médiatique il ya la
posture judiciaire c'est aujourd'hui de
montrer ses armes et les armes légales
des armes juridiques dont on dispose
c'est la posture médiatique n'oublions
pas que on parle d'un sujet qui
passionne les français qui se prêtait
d'abord la succession qui passe est
d'autant plus les français qu'il s'agit
de la succession d'un grand artiste d'un
artiste un peu légendaire en france donc
forcément il ya cette posture médiatique
qui fait qu on essaye d'exercer aussi
une espèce de l'influencé médiatique
pour amener les parties où l'une des
parties en tout cas à trouver un accord
afin que je crois pas du tout que ça va
tu veux trouver un accord pas du tout
maintenant si ça va pas durer cinq ou
dix ans chez moi je vous dit je vous
fais un pari ça va durer au moins cinq
ans et beaucoup plus parce qu'il y avait
alors pas de preuves de l'argent est-ce
que c'est comme si vous faisiez la
matinale d'europe 1 vous auriez
peut-être traiter de cette affaire ou
pas oui au début
voilà un peu moins mais un peu moi même
quand je fais des remplacements de
laurent delahousse au vin alors moi je
suis en contact avec des avocats de
l'une et des autres il ya un petit peu
d'instrumentalisation commissariat les
avocats des deux côtés mais nous on veut
bien discuter mais voilà c'est eux qui
veulent pas non moi je vous laisse
écouter mais c'est elle qui veut pas et
au bout du compte c'est tout ça est un
truc de qom et de grosse grosse
manipulation moi je pense qu'il faudrait
lever le tout petit peu le pied et que
là on est quand même dans des gens tant
roland perez explique on est dans du
droit en descendant dans des affaires
qui sont très pointus et là chacun
s'autorise avoir un avis moi j'ai pas de
vision est très bien alors merci roland
vous restez un petit peu avec nous avec
nous vous dites quoi vous dit que ça va
ils vont trouver un accord où ça va
durer cinq ou dix ans dit la vérité ce
que vous pensez quoi
à ce stade aujourd'hui je pense que au
regard de la prochaine audience si
demain le tribunal de grande instance de
nanterre s'estime compétent estime que
le droit français doit être appliquée
s'estime complétant je pense qu'un
accord peut intervenir si c'était
aujourd'hui d'une manche une manche aura
été véritablement qu'elle écoute un
disque de johnny hallyday à la place
exactement c'est vrai bravo bravo thomas